good morning everybody today is a very
exciting day because we are getting some
actual solid gameplay I'm hoping this
video is 13 minutes and 47 seconds of
The Legend of Zelda the kingdom which I
still can't believe is coming out in a
few months it's
just unfathomable my brain can't process
that yet uh any minute now Zelda's
coming out we're gonna be playing it
it's wild um also before we go any
further
my face is messed up from boxing it's
gonna keep happening over the next four
weeks because I have a boxing match on
April 15th that I have to train for so
just excuse my swollen eyes please uh
let's get to it it is time for the
legends of the Kingdom Mr ionoma
gameplay demonstration I'm watching this
on the Nintendo of America YouTube
channel let's do it
hello everyone
I'm AJ alanuma producer of The Legend of
Zelda series
first I have some news I love news
development on the Legend of Zelda tears
of the kingdom is now complete it's done
thank you very much for waiting
many of you are looking forward
unfathomable and we've released a few
trailers so far
although it'll just be a brief Glimpse
I'm going to actually play the game for
you all today and show you what it's
like
excited
okay let's begin sounds great
here we are in the land of Hyrule
like The Legend of Zelda breath of the
wild there is a vast world too I like
links cool tattoo of course it's not
just the same world as is it's changed
in many ways if we talk about all of the
changes today we'll run out of time so
we hope you'll seek them out for
yourself it does look very similar
reaches High into the sky yeah it is
you'll notice some land masses floating
up there we call them Sky Islands
the UI looks wearing something how do
you get to the sky islands when they're
so high up there yeah I was wondering
if we take a look oh something's falling
from the sky
do you see it
yeah I wonder what that is let's head
over to it
is that like a lift
yeah
here it is
okay let's use one of Link's new
abilities this link looks so cool I love
what he's doing this on the rock that
just fell
look it started Rising
this blue line thing is recall which
rewinds an object's movement
since I just used recall on the Fallen
Rock I can now rise into the sky we're a
lot closer to the sky islands
let's use the paraglider to reach one of
them
there are a few other Sky Islands
floating here too
I made it
I'm very curious about the potential
there are a lot of potential to reach
the sky island so we hope you'll try a
few different methods
I can't wait to see like the physics
YouTube video stuff that comes out of
this the coolest just like on the
surface there are several man-made
structures some trees are also growing
here
you won't see many of those yellow trees
on the surface though
let's walk around for a bit
pretty it's very Elder ring
there's a branch on the ground when you
find something like this you should pick
it up it might come in handy later
let's continue
oh something's there this is a brand new
enemy called a construct we'll fight it
using the branch we just picked up
ah the branch broke I wonder if it's not
good this is the demo building there's a
branch and it does look pretty empty but
I guess I speeded it I guess I thought
that of the breath of the wild gameplay
too and it didn't end up actually
feeling anything
[Music]
we've now explored more of this Sky
Island
as expected fighting with just a branch
won't get us very far
also this branch is almost broken so
here's another one of Link's new
abilities if we use this branch and the
rock over here and do this
look we can stick them together
this is called fuse that's awesome
objects together to create new weapons
with various effects
let's take on another construct with
this fused weapon I'm so excited to see
what like the community does two of them
at once like how creative we can get
with this
oh we beat one Accord the weapons attack
has definitely improved
the other that's so cool but this weapon
has much better durability
you can do all sorts of things
you confuse two weapons for example if
we take this long stick and fuse it with
a pitchfork
we can create a weapon with a much
longer attack range oh my God I love it
that's with this we don't have to get
too close to enemies and we can safely
attack from a distance
you can also fuse Arrows with materials
in your inventory for instance try
fusing this Leaf to an arrow well I want
to infuse it with some meat
fuse an ice Elemental material to an
arrow and
you can freeze far away enemies that's
such a cool evolution of the cooking
mechanic very useful
in addition
let's see
ah there's a bird flying around if
you're out hunting you might feel that
aiming with an arrow is too difficult
apparently my eyes can't track
fast-moving objects as of late so my
shots rarely land
so at times like these
here's an eyeball you can get by
defeating monsters
fuse it to an arrow and
whoa combed in on the target that's cool
let's try this on another bird
I'll just fire in that General Direction
that's very simple
on what you stick together the
fusibility could also be beneficial for
hunting it's really exciting
I've used a mushroom to my shield now
you're probably wondering if this has
any use I am yeah well this mushroom is
actually a Puffs room oh my God I want
to cosplay this link so bad he looks so
cool
I blocked with the shield okay there's
smoke now the enemies lost sight of
links so attack
that's really neat yeah if you struggle
with combat you can take down enemies
using similar methods
in the previous game you'd usually get
powerful weapons by defeating strong
enemies but in this game fusing even the
weakest weapon with something else could
turn it into a useful weapon there are
even more gameplay options for sticking
things together let me demonstrate man
it's gonna be so interesting Islands
even have Rivers
we'll want to cross this one but
swimming across it well the river's too
wide for that we need a boat confused
about together I think we saw this in a
previous anything that resembles a boat
around here
so we'll lift up this log and attach it
to a second log
oh my god let's do one more people are
gonna do such cool stuff with us here
and attach a third log
it's a makeshift raft this is another
new ability called Ultra hand
even though the logs are currently
attached they can be detached let's
modify the shape of the raft
what is this green goop
you can always attach things or detach
them like this
now if we put this on the water it's
made of wood so the buoyancy will keep
it afloat just for a second okay this is
super interesting right and I'm very
impressed I I consistently felt like
Nintendo was very Innovative
um I wonder if doing this means that we
will have like a community of people who
approach this game like Minecraft where
we just see people building giant Forts
and giant houses
rather than actually playing the game at
all like if we just see
people building crazy stuff and it could
take off in a way that that Minecraft or
even like a Roblox type did like I feel
like there's so much potential for a
community to use this like on YouTube or
twitch that um
I don't know how limited it is like how
many things you can stick together at
once but that that's really exciting to
me
that maybe that'll be the first thing I
try is like see what crazy stuff I can
build that's very cool
we've made a simplified version of a
boat
however it won't move in its current
state so we'll need something to propel
it forward
if you go to there
is something here let's try hitting it
oh a wind it's blowing wind
looks like we found a fan why don't we
try attaching it
we'll attach another one
what happens if you only attach one like
will it just
how good are the physics
okay they're attached
all right let's try moving the boat
hey it's moving oh what's this feeling
pretty fast with the Wind from the fans
maybe that's the since we added two fans
we should be able to cross the river in
no time
all right we reached the other side
in the most recent trades
riding a large car and a flying machine
those Vehicles actually made the game
from the start instead you'll be able to
freely craft them on your own there are
all sorts of objects you'll come across
in this game and depending on how you
use your imagination you can do a lot
with them
so try crafting different things this is
so impressive and not at all what I want
from Zelda in a way that it's like
nobody asked for this you just did
something unbelievably cool
it's not what you expect from a Zelda
game at all okay watch this
look I passed right through the ceiling
this new ability is called Ascend if
you're in a place with a ceiling you can
go through
you can't do it everywhere
he's gonna do in dungeons
does this game have done there are some
respects what's great about this ability
is that as long as there's a ceiling you
can use it anywhere
for example this place has a cave with a
hill right above it
if we use the Ability here
how do dungeons work
come on keep going
okay we emerged at the top of the hill
you had to use stamina to climb a
mountain but in this game if there's a
mountain with a cave like this one you
can now get to the top without having to
climb all the way up here's another
example imagine you're stuck in a cage
if it's got a ceiling you know what to
do right exactly
oh there's another construct
it seems to be holding a strange weapon
some enemies are equipped with fused
weapons so battles will play out a bit
differently from the previous game
ah it blew me away with wind that's cool
looks like it's got some sort of fan
ah I got pushed off
oh well let's just return to the surface
you can quickly descend from the sky to
the surface like this
in the sky you'll be able to look out
across the land
you can also search for destinations
that pique your interest
once you've chosen your destination you
can speed things up like this certainly
the most
um it's all the game
on the surface
yeah there are still so many things I'd
like to show you but let's leave it at
that for now
foreign
I'm sure some of you watching me play
were thinking wait if you could do that
then maybe you could do this correct
in this game you can do a lot of things
just by thinking about what's even
possible
there's still a lot of new gameplay
Mysteries and encounters we couldn't
show today but they're all jam-packed
into this unfamiliar Hyrule and we hope
you'll use your imagination to explore
it
that's all for today man thank you for
watching
[Music]
so
this is super interesting like very very
interesting and very exciting I'm really
excited
um to see what other people do with this
one which is so nice man
I don't need it oh God I love what like
swearing
um
[Music]
however everything we've seen so far of
this game hasn't appealed to me that
much in terms of the way that I play I'm
not the kind of player who spends a ton
of time building stuff in a game so
it's very exciting it's super unique
it's super creative and I can't wait to
see what other people do with it but I'm
actually less excited about it until
a Zelda game if that makes any sense at
this point like
oh
the pro control is so nice I'm gonna get
that pro control
let me get that that's gorgeous
um
yeah but I guess like I have I have a
ton of faith that it's going to be a
good Zelda game like they know how to
make a Zelda game at this point but I
feel like that's the stuff I've seen
less of I'm very impressed by everything
we saw here just isn't something I'm
necessarily going to spend a ton of time
doing or maybe I will I'm just not
usually that kind of player I definitely
get very creative with Minecraft but I
get more aesthetically creative than
functionally creative so like I like
building like a big tree house or an
underwater house or something
um that is aesthetically appealing to me
and I'm always less interested in
you know playing with with redstone or
the engineering side of it um and that's
what it seems like this game has a focus
on so I wonder what the balance is like
for a player like me who's less into
that kind of stuff is it still just the
causality experience where we're just
going to Dungeons and and exploring and
taking out bosses and finding Keys
whatever
um
I have faith that it will be there it's
just that we've seen a bit less of it
but yeah that's my takeaway from this is
like I'm super impressed it's very
exciting to see what the internet does
with it it's slightly less exciting for
me so I think I'm at this point not as
excited about this game as I was about
breath of the wild but I think it's
maybe also that it's one of the first
times that they've made a Zelda that's
effectively in the same place
um technically they're all in the same
place but it looks so similar so it
doesn't have as much of a draw
still very excited about it and still
gonna play it
but yeah I uh I just hope that the coral
Zelda is still there I imagine that it
will be though which is does it makes
less sense to focus on it I guess in
their presentations when it's kind of
guaranteed it's a Zelda game you know
what you're gonna get what you didn't
expect to get is crazy crafting
mechanics that look to be fair very cool